well the slow decline among gas prices
continues here in the las vegas valley
and across the country though they're
still historically high take a look here
our current average for a gallon of
regular unleaded sits at five dollars
and 26 cents today down from 5.28
yesterday but much more than the
national average at four dollars and
eighteen cents and those gas prices are
starting to cause some major problems on
the road that's right as joe moeller
shows the nevada freeway service is
helping more people who are trying to
make it as far as possible on empty
with every trip to the gas station
costing more and more some drivers are
waiting as long as possible before they
have to come back to a gas station but
it appears some drivers are just waiting
too long it can get busy while everyone
is on their daily commutes my route is
i-15. these trucks and the drivers
inside are hard at work i show up at 4
30 and then start at 5. freeway patrol
technician tim stankovic has noticed a
trend lately so we get a lot of people
that run out of gas i already have one
this morning
i had three yesterday now a quarter of
the people he helps a day are out of gas
we were with him tuesday and a short
time after we hopped in his truck white
utility truck southbound south of sarah
we came across his second empty tank
that day at around 8 a.m hey what's
going on
govich pulled out the cones the tank and
gave the driver enough to get to a gas
station
george shea works in construction i'm
out of the gas i don't make it to the
stone he says he would have been stuck
and admitted getting around is costing
him a lot more 160 a week running out of
gas can cause a problem if somebody
stalls out in the middle of the freeway
it's going to cause a
traffic congestion the goal is to keep
people safe and moving people are
struggling and people are trying to make
ends meet sometimes gas is super
expensive right the nevada freeway
service doesn't necessarily respond to
calls they say the first thing you
should do is call the nevada state
police if you find yourself in need of
help on the side of the road stankovic
says the best thing you can do is to
make sure you have enough gas before you
hit the road reporting at decatur 95 joe
muller live local now